going everybody it's warren welcome back
to my channel the cosmic wonder where we
talk all things marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe
over this past weekend we had cc xp and
it was a
huge disappointment not just for marvel
fans but for fans in general of movies
they didn't really show anything new
they didn't release any new trailers
with the exception of a wonder woman
1984 trailer that didn't really have
much new footage at all
and to top it all off even though it was
rumored to be happening at ccxp
we didn't get any new spider-man 3 news
at all
but just because we didn't get any news
at ccxp doesn't mean that we won't get
any news
this month because the executive at sony
did promise us a first look at
spider-man
in december of 2020 so hopefully that's
still true but today
some very exciting news has been
revealed by deadline
and deadline says that some big marvel
news is coming in just a few
days including the announcements of new
marvel
and lucasfilm projects on its investor
day on december 10th i'll break down
everything you need to know in this
video but first if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the latest mcu news and so you
can enter this week's giveaway for a
chance to win a zombie
mysterio funko pop so an article from
deadline was released this morning and
deadline is a very reputable trade
source they have many
many connections in the movie and tv
industry and in their report this
morning they say that a lot of marvel
news is coming
now it had already been confirmed by
disney ceo that on
december 10th on disney's investor day
meeting
they would be talking more about marvel
more about lucasfilm and more about
disney plus
and this apparently remains true
according to deadline on december 10th
on the investor day
marvel is going to unveil some new
projects and according to deadline it is
going to be for disney plus but
also for theaters as well the article
reads as follows
disney on december 10th will announce
its upcoming slate
while the studio will solidify what
deadline revealed recently
that the tom hanks starrer pinocchio
peter pan and the emma stone star
carella will bypass movie theaters to
become disney plus releases
the studio will also announce new
projects from marvel
lucasfilm and pixar that will encompass
tv
as well as theatrical so a couple of
things here
in this article one is that disney is
going to unveil their new slate
and this is going to encompass marvel
disney plus shows as well as marvel
movies
so there is a chance that some of
marvel's phase 5 could be revealed
in this meeting after all we have all of
phase 4 already officially announced if
they're going to announce
new projects that has to be for phase 5.
now i'm not expecting an
entire phase 5 slate reveal but again
any new projects that they are going to
announce in this meeting have to be for
phase 5 because we already have phase 4.
and again the article is very specific
they say the studio will
also announce new projects for marvel
lucasfilm and pixar that will encompass
tv as well as theatrical so it's not
just disney plus shows that are going to
be announced because we know that marvel
does have a
ton of disney plus shows planned to be
released within the next few years
and some of those are going to be
revealed in this meeting but also
some movies are going to be revealed as
well so a lot of exciting things coming
up in just three days
the next thing that this article reveals
is that disney isn't against
putting movies straight to disney plus
as the article mentions they're going to
be putting pinocchio
peter pan and cruella straight to disney
plus bypassing a theatrical release date
this means that they could do this for
black widow as well now so far it seems
like marvel really does want black widow
to release in the theaters but now with
disney pushing all of these movies to
disney plus
and studios like warner brothers
announcing that they'll be releasing a
lot of movies straight to hbo max
some simultaneously releasing in
theaters as well
this is a sign that marvel could in fact
put black widow on disney plus but
that doesn't mean they can't release it
theatrically as well
but make no mistake despite whatever you
hear disney is considering putting black
widow on video on demand on their disney
plus streaming service
they did it for mulan they're now doing
it for pinocchio peter pan and cruella
and their direct competitions are doing
it as well so it's definitely on their
radar and if theaters continue to stay
closed and closed down it's going to be
something that they eventually have to
do
but in some good news it looks like
we're going to be ending 2020 off the
right way getting some new
marvel news and hopefully getting that
spider-man 3 teaser we were promised by
the end of the year as well
so let me know what you think about this
in the comments down below let me know
how excited you are to finally get some
new marvel news
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all the latest mcu news and for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof